qui sont directement touchés par la
guerre en Ukraine en revanche on reçoit
ici tous les jours on en est où la
France de la mobilisation de vous voyez
les rapports entre la Russie et la
France c'est quoi mais les rapports
entre la Russie et la France ne sont pas
très bons mais je crois qu'il faut voir
les situations économiques de chaque
côté n'est-ce pas quelle est la
situation économique en Russie qui est
la situation économique en France là le
taux d'inflation actuel à Moscou et
trois fois celui que nous avons ici mais
ça n'a rien à voir
dans l'histoire non mais la Russie
souffre infiniment normal ah c'est
normal mais encore faut-il le dire c'est
normal
mais c'est eux qui ont voulu faire la
guerre à l'Ukraine donc c'est normal
lorsque je dise les Français qui nous
regardent ce soir c'est pourquoi eux ils
sont impactés pourquoi aujourd'hui
est-ce que on dit une connerie mais
voilà une victime les victimes
collatérales directement se confient
c'est les boulangers par exemple qui
sont aujourd'hui en train de fermer tous
les jours les petits artisans boulangers
parce que l'électricité c'est plus
possible quand votre partie
d'électricité elle passe de 1 à 5 à un
moment vous pouvez plus donc
la Russie qui soit dans des difficultés
économiques c'est normal c'est un pays
en guerre nous la France on n'est pas en
guerre ça doit se résorber puisque avant
de rentrer sur ce plateau je regardais
le cours du pétrole quand indicateur le
cours du pétrole est à 72 dollars
aujourd'hui ce soir ça veut dire qu'il
est un peu plus faible il n'était avant
la guerre donc les choses sont en train
de se tasser
l'électricité bon elle relève d'un autre
marché de notre système effectivement
européens
ça va rebaisser ça va dur à la guerre en
Ukraine tant qu'il y aura la guerre en
Ukraine en Russie l'électricité va
rester non elle a commencé déjà à
baisser on le voit sur notre personnel
mais l'essence c'est quelques centimes
vous avez on est content
si tu as 1 40 quand le pétrole est à 78
dollars pourquoi il a un pourquoi il a
un 78 maintenant à 66 vous me donnez la
station j'y vais hein c'est à 78 à 9
dans le Loir-et-Cher oui mais moi je
suis à Paris dans le Val-d'Oise
j'habite j'habite dans le Val-d'Oise
quoi c'est ça le problème parce que on
en parle souvent ici et moi j'entends de
plus en plus de Français dire il faut le
dire voilà qui viennent me voir et qui
me dit Cyril cette guerre en Ukraine ça
nous a foutu dans la merde c'est ce que
le président Macron a appelé les les le
prix de la liberté il faut faire payer
le prix de la liberté en réalité qu'on
donne des armes à l'Ukraine pour se
défendre après tout c'est un pays
souverain qui a été attaqué ça peut
s'entendre mais la question des
sanctions qu'on a prise contre la Russie
était absurde mais sanctions n'ont
jamais fonctionné n'ont jamais fait
plier un pays la Russie ne s'est pas
écroulée économiquement souvenez-vous
le maire on va mettre bien sûr
Guillaume et tu as raison c'est bien que
tu le dis ce soir parce que faut dire
les choses il est 21h06 on est en direct
il y en a beaucoup qui nous rejoignent
actuellement euh les Français ils se
disent ils ont ils nous ont dit plein de
choses on va mettre si vous avez dit à
genoux l'économie russe on va prendre
des sanctions drastiques pour faire que
la Russie va pouvoir devoir déposer les
armes et arrêter la guerre très vite on
le voit ça marche pas du tout par contre
on a des Français en revanche qui se
retrouvent et de plus en plus de
Français qui qui se retrouvent dans la
merde à cause de la guerre en Ukraine
donc qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit à ces
Français
je pense que c'est vraiment une guerre
qui n'est pas la nôtre c'est très
important à comprendre c'est que moi ce
qui me frappe dans cette guerre c'est
qu'on ne peut pas ne pas choisir son
camp on est sommet en quelque sorte par
les États-Unis aujourd'hui il y a des
auditions très intéressantes à
l'Assemblée nationale sur les ingérences
étrangers il y a eu l'Allemagne il y a
eu la France il y a eu François Fillon
et Jean-Pierre Chevènement on voulait
montrer qu'il y avait des ingérences en
France François Fillon a dit moi j'ai
pas touché un copain de la Russie il a
démissionné de ses mandats d'ailleurs
avant l'invasion et Jean-Pierre
Chevènement a dit mais attendez moi j'ai
été c'est le gouvernement français qui
m'a demandé de représenter les intérêts
français auprès de la Russie c'était
très intéressant ces auditions on en a
pas parlé mais Jean-Pierre Chevènement a
expliqué en 2008 en 2009 en 2010
non-stop jusqu'à 2014 invasion de la
Crimée les alertes rouges de Poutine ne
touchez pas à l'Ukraine n'avancez pas ça
va mal se passer une fois deux fois
quatre fois dix fois et on a joué avec
ça
[Musique]
je dis simplement comme ça il explique